one of the many things that's so great
about the crown is that their every
aspect of the production from lighting
to sound to cinematography to
performances it's all so incredible can
you sort of talk you both have worked on
so many projects what was it like for
you being on set for the first time and
experiencing the way this production is
made
well I think we we had it easy easier in
that respect than the people making the
first uh series because we came onto it
series five knowing the quality of the
the work that had preceded us and
um you know you can
I this might interest you I found it
with going into Game of Thrones season
five that you know people now say who do
we need for season five to get this show
on the road we'll get Jonathan price in
well they did the same with the crown
and you go on to these shows and the
reason they're so good is because of the
commitment of everybody and I went into
Game of Thrones especially thinking oh
it would be cynical by now you know
they're a worldwide hit not at all they
work as hard and day one as they were
doing on you know whatever day 200 and
it's the same with the crown there's the
extraordinary commitment to doing the
best work you can possibly do and that
has to come from the writing
you've got a great script and that
demands
directors designers they will all want
to attach to something like that and
that's why you know all of us come in
for this season uh the previous actors
from three and four one and two then you
go right we have to keep we have to keep
the bar high no we have to make the bar
a lot higher not not because it was it
was low but you go we can't let this go
on do we have to just keep going and
going and and if you look around you
everyone in the room is doing that and
that's a a great feeling to be part of
and also a responsibility you know I
always feel very responsible if I'm
playing any sort of leading role that I
have to you lead from the front
and you want to set an example to
everyone there that you know this is how
we work hard by
um focusing by recognizing everyone
else's work by being just part of this
absolutely beautiful I think tapestry of
work that Peter Morgan has created not
only are you playing real people but you
are also playing people that um other
performers have done the last few
seasons do you sort of binge watch the
first Four Seasons or do you sort of say
you know um I'm just gonna you know how
do you sort of get ready well you know
what the formula of the show is that
every two seasons there's going to be a
different cast playing the same people
but it will be their version of
Elizabeth or Philip at that time in
their lives everything moves on
um and
I didn't purp I mean I'd watched the
whole preceding series but I didn't
refer back to it what we both of us
referred to initially and constantly are
the real people referring to Philip
referring to Elizabeth and learning from
them and uh no everything's everything
is different you you don't feel you're
stepping into anybody's shoes because
you know we are how many years later you
know we're at this age we're not playing
the queen in her fort I'm not playing
her in her 40s
um with prosthetics I'm the right age
for now so and I think that's a really
clever idea that Peter and the producers
had in the first place it also gives a a
it's an added excitement to the series
that you know is going to be as a free
song when you see the new actors come on
and see what their interpretation is
going to be like so it's not like you
know an end a soap opera that's gone on
forever and you've watched you can look
back and you see the the Starlet and now
she's 87 and she's still playing the
same role
[Music]
I thought I would bring her age up there
you go sorry I know you guys are filming
the final season right now I'm obviously
very much looking forward to it uh what
can you tease in terms of how the
production's been going
well we uh well to be honest you know we
started on the Wednesday and the queen
died on Thursday so it's been colored
obviously by those events uh nothing has
changed within the the series
um
and
um there's no way I would tell you
anything about it I don't know how many
I don't care how many superheroes you
got behind you you're not going to get
past this so
um all that's as I mean so it did really
affect us all I think everyone was very
saddened and uh thrown off course and
um and yet one new one had to continue
um which we are doing and have done so
um and and it is odd having to talk
about something that you're still doing
I mean because I've never done a series
so I'd maybe you know for other people
doing long series you do that all the
time but um this is a first for me so
it's um
I'll I'll be quite glad when this is on
now maybe just go back to work on that
note I need to stop I'm just going to
say seriously you both did such great
work and um uh you know congrats on the
season's fantastic great thank you thank
you